the most important thing is your mind
make no mistake about that right now the
only thing that is holding you back I
promise you and whatever excuse you're
telling yourself it's bull the only
thing that's holding you back is the way
that you think about yourself in the
world that's it flat you have not built
the mechanisms in your mind that you
need to free yourself from the Matrix
and boys and girls The Matrix has you
who knows David Foster Wallace
this is water in the talk what he makes
clear is the fish is the last one to
realize that it's in water think about
it from a human perspective we had to
discover air we had to discover gravity
they're so ubiquitous you literally
don't see them you take them for granted
as just being there and that's how
people take their belief system
right now you think you're capable of
certain things and incapable of others
and that is your water hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because in my first business I was
making 300 bucks a month I quit on my
business partner and the thing that
saved me was studying the stories of
super successful entrepreneurs so I hope
that this story today helps give you the
motivation you need because I still
needed to myself so today let's live
your best believe life and get the
mindset of high Achievers enjoy
and until you can identify it until you
can see that you're telling yourself
lies and they are disempowering Lies by
the way because I am not some Grand fan
of the truth
I'm a grand fan of doing and believing
that which moves you towards your goals
do and believe
that which moves you towards your goals
that's it once you put that belief at
the core of your being you will be
amazed at what you're able to accomplish
when I say take the red pill what I'm
talking about is waking up to the way
the world really is
the amount of potential that you have I
always say is nearly
Unlimited
but I only say that so I don't have to
get into stupid arguments with people
about throwing absolutely ridiculous
things out just to try to defeat the
notion
and that's somebody who wants me to be
wrong but ask yourselves right now if my
message is you can do anything you set
your mind to without limitation don't
you hope I'm right
and even if I'm wrong how much farther
will you go simply because you were
willing to believe humans lead with
belief humans lead with belief you won't
take the first step down to any path
unless you believe you can actually get
where you're going and this is where
people get stuck in The Matrix
you don't push yourself hard enough you
don't make big enough demands you think
small you dream small you make small
demands of yourself if you want to see
what big demands look like look at David
Goggins anybody know David Goggins
for those of you who don't let me tell
you a quick story David Goggins is a
Navy SEAL he wanted to honor Fallen
seals to do that he wanted to pick the
hardest thing that he could think of it
was a 135 mile race the person who put
on the race said you can't enter my race
unless you run 100 miles in a 24-hour
period have you the answer was no he
said there's one four days from now if
you can complete four days to weigh 250
pounds in four days if you can complete
a hundred mile race literally running
around a high school track think about
how torturous that would be if you can
complete
a hundred miles
in 24 hours then you get to run my race
and raise the funds for your charity
so David decides he's going to run that
race
he wasn't prepared he was overweight
by mile 70 he had broken both of his
feet he had shin splints his calf
muscles were beginning to tear off the
bone
he sat into a chair because he literally
had nothing left to give
he urinated on himself blood because he
couldn't move he couldn't get up to go
to the restroom so he defecated on
himself
and as he's sitting there in the chair
peeing blood in total Agony with feces
on his back
the only question he had was what do I
need to do to finish the remaining 30
miles
and so he taped his feet so that they
would go numb and he would stop feeling
the pain of the broken feet he ate
something so that he would have the
needed energy to keep going and he got
up and he started walking
and he walked for I don't remember how
many miles and his wife said at this
pace
you're not going to finish
and so he ran the remaining 19 miles
broken feet
stress fractures in his Shins
blood
excrement and he finished on time
that's what a human being is capable of
that's what a human being is capable of
we limit ourselves and it's only us
there's nobody else that's doing it to
you you've chosen to adopt those beliefs
and once you've pushed yourself outside
of that comfort zone what becomes
possible is absolutely miraculous now I
choose to believe that my potential is
Limitless and because of that I've gone
from scrounging in my couch cushions to
find enough change to put gas in my car
that is a true story to building a
billion dollar business
all right how do you do it if this is
about building your mindset how
to me it's about mind the gap there is a
gap between who you are now and who you
need to become and that Gap is the gap
of skill set plain and simple remember
you're an adaptation machine your job is
to place yourself under stress
and then force yourself to grow
so back to Mr yoked
you don't get those muscles by looking
at the weights you get those muscles by
going under the weight and not stopping
when it hurts you stop when you can no
longer recruit the muscles enough to
move the weight that's when you're done
and when you're able to do that what
you're actually doing is tearing down
the muscle fiber
and a lot of people when they begin
working out they don't realize that's
actually the name of the game the name
of the game is to break the muscle down
and then the body comes and builds it
back up
the conscious part is tearing it down
your job is to put yourself in stressful
situations your job is to push yourself
to the limit of what you think you're
capable of and then go past that and
when you're able to push yourself past
that when you're able to get into the
Goggins reps as I call it when you're
able to exist in that zone long past
where it started hurting long past when
it got boring long past when you were
terrified that you'd never be able to do
it that's when you'll begin to adapt
because you're telling your body adapt
or die
that's how you're going to get where you
want to go mindset number two is believe
in your dreams with Brendan burchard in
this episode we're going to talk about
how do you keep believing in your dreams
when the struggle gets too hard when
it's challenging when you don't know
what to do when you're at that corner of
it could go good or bad you're scared or
you're just not getting the support
around you that would make you feel like
maybe this is something you could
actually accomplish or maybe you come
from a circumstance where it just
doesn't seem likely at all how do you
believe in what you're doing and I get
that because you know my whole career
has been in some way or another a
struggle against my own doubts all along
the way as much as people say gosh
you're so confident you know you're the
high performance guy and everything else
I'm like yeah but it doesn't mean I
don't struggle matter of fact I probably
put myself in situations where I must be
challenged and I must struggle more than
any normal sane person you know I'm
constantly pushing myself all the time
because as I evaluate struggle is
something to be honored you know it used
to be struggle a struggle was something
that was was truly honored by people
they thought that was something that
built character they thought that that
was something that was good and and now
we've got to be such a convenient driven
Society that's into ease and so much to
just I think an unbelievable level of
engage I'm sorry entitlement where
people don't think they have to earn it
and I'm always like wait you know if you
have a dream never forget if you knock
on the door of opportunity that it is
work who answers you know it takes a lot
of work to achieve your bigger dreams to
become the best you who you can be to
serve more to create more to contribute
at that highest level man it's a lot of
work and I know I'm preaching the choir
I know you get this so what can I share
with you about this struggle you know
it's been for me at 20 years learning
about personal development and teaching
about personal development it's been you
know my effort and everything I do and
I'm so passionate about helping people
reach that next level I had to go out
and figure out how to do it for myself
and believe in myself so here's where I
did along the way and what I advise our
Olympic clients do our Fortune 50 CEO
clients and our entrepreneurs or our
starter those who are starting and
struggling or stay-at-home moms doesn't
matter the advice is the same thing four
things to keep believing in the dream
and advancing toward the dreams number
one and I know you've heard this but my
question is how much do you do it and
that is visually visualization and we
call it highly engaged visualization
visualization where you're seeing
yourself doing something and you're
emotively there you're literally closing
your eyes and meditating on the
experience you're seeing it feeling it
sensing it and it's not the kind of
visualization you've probably been
taught to do which is just all the
buoyant Victory everything's great
Victory hey hey everything's awesome
perfect it's the visualization where you
also Imagine see and feel the struggle
on Purp purpose let me give you an
example lots of people when they're new
to you know Performance training uh and
never had a lot of experience they would
say oh what you know if you're going to
run a marathon imagine yourself Crossing
that vision and finish line you know
your arms up and victory everything is
great you cross that finish line there's
your family and they give you big hugs
and you feel great still vital energize
ready to kick some butt you know you
could run another 20 miles you're the
strongest most powerful you ever and I'm
like oh wow you know that's just a
person who hasn't done a lot of training
or actual high performance coaching in
their life because the better thing to
imagine is what happens at Mile 13
it to imagine yourself running to
starting running running strong but also
seeing and sensing and feeling yourself
at Mile 13 when that decision Point
comes to want to quit
that's where I want you to also enter
the scene and visualize seeing yourself
struggle like seeing the perspiration
seeing the heartache seeing the hurt the
pain that like I can't run anymore dude
seeing yourself make a decision at that
point to be resilient to keep at it to
see the charge come back on your face to
see yourself working through the
struggle is the most important
visualization you can do what would you
say to yourself when it sucks not just
see yourself validated it's about look
the real truth of achieving Any Dream is
that struggle that effort that push and
I know you know this so my question is
when is the last time you just gave
yourself a few moments
free away from you know playing on the
phone freeway from the internet to just
sit down by yourself to visualize and
daydream about your dreams about the
activities involved in that about how
you would struggle through about what it
would feel like to be victorious all of
it the whole thing the messy part the
ugly part what would you say to yourself
when it gets hard that's what you need
to do to truly actualize a dream we got
to begin with seeing it and sensing it
the good the bad the easy the difficult
and the Victory I would say the second
thing that we have to do to believe in a
dream not just see it and sense and feel
it but we got to do research and
unfortunately our society has gotten so
lazy in their research it's it's
unfortunate especially where I'm in here
in the United States our educational
system has gotten so bad and people are
so lazy and I don't mean to mean speak
to everybody but you know there's a very
big lazy culture right now where people
won't take the time they won't even read
a book on their topic they're like oh a
whole book you know they'll read a Blog
article and pretend it's enough it's
like no you know what the highest
performers they're always researching
and they're doing real research I mean
they don't read one book on the topic
they read seven you know they don't
interview one person they interview a
person a week they don't uh read one
blog post they read them print them out
highlight them create binders I mean if
you want to become world class you got
to know what is else is out there what
other other lessons people have learned
you can't keep inventing the wheel you
gotta someone else has already figured
this out research them stand on their
shoulders you know what a lot of people
don't understand is Einstein while he
was a genius he also was prolific in the
amount of research he did on on theories
that have already been proven and where
their holes might be he was constantly
researching everything not just putting
new ideas into play he was busting up on
old ideas and standing on the shoulders
of giants who'd already made major
breakthroughs that now he could apply in
new areas with new insights new metaphor
new discovery you got to get back into
reading and understanding and paying
attention but you cannot just get into
analysis paralysis either and that's why
you also have to on a daily basis
actualize your dreams what I mean by
that well I'm sure you I hope you've
read some Abraham Maslow and and this
concept of self-actualization becoming
our best
but you have to actually show up every
day and inch yourself forward toward
these streams and not only show up every
day and once in a while inch yourself I
mean every day you have to actually take
an action that moves you forward not
just research not just thinking look the
power of intention is great but without
any initiative it's dead right A Dream
is great but without any movement it's
dead you have to be moving towards every
day you can send an email every day you
can make a call every day you can write
something every day you can create
something every day you can contribute
something every day but it has to be
daily otherwise it will never become
actualized the highest performers in the
world didn't get there because they were
lucky they worked at it longer than
everyone else they had a better work
ethic and it's not that they necessarily
always worked harder they work smarter
because they were doing the research
they were taking the time to visualize
how they would be distinct different
different how they would survive the
tough times they really kept at it
keep every single day momentum going and
if you don't do that there's no chance
last piece so easy fourth piece here
Community you need to get in a community
where you can get feedback you need
either a coach who can give you some
direct one-to-one feedback or Community
to friends so you just go out with maybe
you go to lunch to them once a month you
share everything you're doing they give
you some feedback or you shoot a video
you send that video out to everybody get
some feedback on it you create important
the PowerPoint practice it with five
people before the big meeting like get
back in the game where you have a
community of people who are giving you
Advanced feedback before you release it
feedback before you do it so that you
get smarter at all of this because you
know nothing makes a dream come more
into life than when you start getting
feedback from other people about your
movement toward the dreams you know
before I shoot a big sales video for one
of my online courses I'll send it out to
15 20 people and get feedback and then
I'll often go reshoot it again you know
or I'll put it out in my community and
I'll see the clicks the conversions and
say it's not let's do it again and it's
that willingness to get the feedback
that will keep your dream alive because
look if it's just in your mind
and you're just doing it by yourself but
you never actually get a positive
Community giving you constructive
feedback towards it it will never be
that that it will never be in the social
realm and when it is in the social realm
it feels more real you know when people
are actually comment I mean it's one
thing to be in an artist and in your
studio painting for yourself all day
that's great but once you get some
feedback on it and constructive feedback
you become you you get that
self-awareness
and that social awareness to contribute
and create at another level mindset
number three is stop being narrow-minded
with Grant Cardone you should write this
down every day this year is either going
to be better for me
or it's going to be worse for me
how many couples in the room how many
married couples in a room
I'm gonna get worse
worse better it's going to get worse my
health is going to get better my health
is going to get worse
[Music]
what I do today will determine whether
it's going to be better or whether it's
going to be worse it will not be up to
trump it will not be up to the Democrats
it will not be up to to something that
happens in Iran it won't be up to the
stock market it's up to you okay you
guys want it to be better or worse how
much better 10x better baby 10x
you don't want it to be a little better
you need to start thinking like this
okay first get rid of the little think
and the old ideas
and the middle class mentality
I'm gonna go to work I'm gonna save some
money I'm gonna put it in the bank I'm
gonna give it to the Man
what's the bank dude the bank doesn't
even keep your money
they hate money
cashes yeah
it's trash
is garbage it's pieces the garbage paper
it is only useful when it is used if
you're taking notes
they didn't teach you this in school
this should have been taught basic fifth
grade sixth grade not in not when in
high school or college cash this is a
piece of paper okay it is a piece of
paper it's worthless this is a piece of
paper this actually has more value this
piece of paper right here has more value
than this piece of paper right here why
because one person has this piece of
paper
[Music]
2 000 people have this data
you understand this piece of paper right
here is useless though until it is used
how many of you were taught to say stuff
how many of you got sticky notes and you
save them
you write you write like 17 different
things on one sticky note
I don't I don't want to use the whole
pad
[Music]
I'm gonna make this I'm gonna make this
sticky pad last the rest of my life
[Music]
okay you got to get rid of the little
thing folks this little think is killing
you let's find out if you got the little
think
how many believe success is a mind game
dude it starts right here you got to fix
this also to make sure you're actually
taking action after watching this video
I've designed a special free worksheet
just for this video the worksheet will
highlight all of the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there mindset number four is celebrate
yourself with Mel Robbins I
believe with all of my heart and being
that every man woman child person
grandparent everybody should Infuse
their days with habits of Celebration
and self-confidence and the fastest and
easiest and most science-backed way
to quickly start to change how you see
yourself
is by adopting a simple habit of
high-fiving your reflection in the
mirror every single morning
now I know exactly what you're thinking
are you serious Mel Robbins that is the
stupidest thing I've ever heard in my
entire life I know I know I know it
sounds dumb but the reason why your
first instinct when you think about
waking up whether in a robe or your
underwear or your PJs or your birthday
suit and walking into that bathroom and
having a moment with yourself and
raising your hand and high-fiving
yourself is because your self-confidence
is in the gutter
you believe some garbage about yourself
you think you're a bad person or you're
unworthy or you're ugly or nobody likes
you or how about this one this was the
story of my life I have [ __ ] up my
life
so badly
I might as well just flush it down the
toilet
you have some narrative in your mind
that is so negative that when you look
in the mirror you see somebody worth
trashing you see what's wrong you pick
apart your appearance and I want to
reverse that because here's the deal
about self-confidence
self-confidence begins with you you
realize the word self is in there right
I can't give you confidence I didn't
give you a little boost I can give you
tools I can encourage you
but confidence is forged in fire
it's something that's within you and
here's the thing I want you to realize
about confidence you are a confident
person that's why you miss feeling that
way you can only miss what you know
you've just been blocked from the
feeling of it
and wherever you are right now in your
life I'm telling you confidence is in
there you just got to figure out how to
tap into it and you've been building
confidence All Along by the way
every time that you have fallen on your
face or you've tried something and
failed or you've gone out and thought
you found the love of your life and then
your heart's broken and then you pick
yourself up again and then you dust
yourself you're building confidence the
entire time because confidence is not
built on the high days confidence is
built on the low ones confidence is
built when you are struggling because
when you see yourself go for something
and fall when you see yourself try and
get knocked down when you see yourself
stand back up after getting abused or
traumatized or discriminated against and
moving ahead you are building this
Reserve within yourself where you know
you can rely on yourself you know you
can face hard things and you can keep
moving forward you know you have your
own back so it's in there your life has
been helping you build it now you've got
to just dig in and tap into it and use
it to shut that critic up in your head
so the way you're going to do that is
every morning I'm not kidding you're
going to raise your hand in the mirror
and high five yourself look at how many
people are doing this you're not the
only one for five Mornings in a row I
want you to high-five yourself
and when you do this I want you to use
the hashtag high five challenge you know
what's happening when you raise your
hand up in the mirror
you are taking the lifetime positive
Association that you have with cheering
for other people believing in other
people
uh celebrating other people
saying let's go to other people and you
are marrying that positive association
with your reflection it is impossible to
raise your hand in the mirror and go I
suck you can't do it because your brain
and the subconscious sees this and
thinks let's go I love you I believe in
you and when you do this every single
morning something incredible happens
first of all you're not going to leave
your bathroom feeling like you're
dragging a boulder you're going to leave
there feeling like the wind's at your
back secondly you're going to have spent
the morning the first thing in the
morning by taking a moment and being
with yourself and not seeing your face
and picking yourself apart but actually
seeing the person
that's underneath the skin the soul
that's behind the face you are going to
shut the critic up you're going to
silence your to-do list and when you
raise your hand like this it also
prompts you to think about the game
you're playing so now you got a moment
to be like oh yeah yay me I'm still here
I can make today a good day in fact what
game do I want to play today just for me
so that's the first thing that you're
going to do you're going to high five
yourself take the high five challenge
which is high five yourself five days in
a row in the mirror take a photo of it
post it on your story tag me so I can
cheer for you and start to notice what
happens something weird happens by day
four when you get out of bed you're
gonna have this weird feeling that
you've never had you're gonna feel like
you're looking forward to seeing
yourself in the mirror because something
weird happens when you start to really
be present with yourself when you
normally walk in the bathroom and you
ignore yourself
you're alone
I think a lot of us feel like we're
alone in our lives when you start to see
yourself
you literally
oh hey hi there Mel Robbins how you
doing you now
as you look forward oh hey girl how you
doing hi Mel Robbins oh hey let's go I
Believe In You Gotta Have a great day
it's almost like when your neighbor
waves you you're seeing yourself you
know now that I've been doing this for a
year I don't feel like I'm alone I feel
like I've got myself and I've got my own
back I feel like this person that I see
in the mirror is the one person that's
going to be with me for my entire life
so I better cheer for her I better
celebrate her I better encourage her and
love her and that's what you're doing
when you do this every morning to
yourself and there are mornings where I
stand in my underwear at my bathroom
sink and even I don't have a word to say
to myself
but I can always do this and it always
lists my mood and it is creating that
deep connection
within me to myself and that's what
builds your confidence confidence is
being comfortable in your own skin
confidence is knowing that you have your
own back confidence is knowing that you
can face something confidence is
believing in your ability to face or
survive or try something and be better
and confidence is being willing to try
and all of those things happen when you
raise your hand every single morning the
second thing that you should do is
um you got to be honest with yourself
if there are things about your
appearance that are within your control
whether it is the shape that you're in
whether it's the health choices that
you're making whether it's how you take
care of yourself in terms of self-love
and you're not taking action in those
areas the lack of action says to your
brain
you don't care about yourself and so
what I want you to do is pick one thing
one behavior that you could do every day
the high fives one of them pick another
one and I want you to practice doing it
and it's a behavior if you think about
the person that you want to become
what's that person do every day that you
don't do right now
and when you start to do the thing that
the person you want to become is doing
you leverage something called behavioral
activation therapy and that is a whole
body of research that says when you act
like the person you want to become it's
the most powerful way to change a habit
it's even uh better therapy than uh talk
therapy because the action proves to
your brain that you're becoming that
person you're seeing the change through
the action and so then the brain catches
up and starts to relate to you like a
person that's confident or a person who
adores their appearance or a person that
celebrates themselves exactly as they
are mindset number five is keep the
momentum up with Dean graziosi what are
you going to do in the next 24 hours to
create momentum doesn't matter where you
are
it matters where we're going
so what are you going to do in the next
24 hours to keep the momentum moving
forward
then what are you going to do in the
next seven days
right you have to write the you can just
write down the numbers and come back and
do this exercise but next 24 hours next
seven days
next 30 days next 60 days and next 90
days I would do a 24 hour a seven day a
30 day a 60 day and a 90-day plan of
what are the outcomes what are you going
to accomplish
next 24 hours I am dedicating a time I'm
going into my journal and I'm going to
dedicate times Tuesdays Wednesdays and
Fridays I am absolutely working on this
that's some that's all I need to do
that's 24 hours what am I going to do in
the next seven days I'm gonna dial in my
DOT and I'm gonna start laying out my
modules okay what do you do in the next
30 days I'm gonna record it I'm gonna
film it the next 60 days I'm gonna be up
on mastermind.com next 90 days I'm going
to start building my Facebook group
I don't know what it is but take the
uncomfortable action to commit yourself
to these put a deadline and let's do the
work and make this happen
here's the thing I want to be here for
you and I'm going to be here for you I'm
spending more time with these groups
than any time in my life
but I still can't do it all for you
you need to take uncomfortable action
you need to know that there's nobody
coming to save us no one coming to save
you no one coming to do it for you
doesn't matter if your liberal
Conservative Republican Democrat in the
middle the right the left super
religious super Christian super
spiritual don't believe it all it
doesn't matter where you are in all the
spectrums there is nobody coming into
our home and saying I know it's been a
little shaky but I got this don't worry
about it it's on us and how liberating
is it when we know it's on us even if
you have disabilities even if you're uh
looked at like anything that you have
that you feel is a negative it doesn't
matter anything you feel it's a positive
it doesn't matter we're still the ones
that make the decisions and we're the
ones that move the needle because no
one's doing it for us we want to change
the world we decide we're going to
change it we want to change the economy
in our home we have to decide we want to
change the amount of time we spend with
family or live into our true purpose or
be the woman or God or man God designed
us to be no one else is doing it for us
but what we can do is what you're doing
gain capabilities from people who've
already been there be a part of a group
bigger than yourself you already got the
capabilities you're already a part of a
group bigger than yourself you already
got the support of this amazing family
you could come in here and say anything
you want in this group will support you
you have all the ingredients so what's
left
you
you have to decide that I'm going all in
and what I would say is when you do your
24 7 30 60 and 90 day breakdown
what you should do is add two things
I would love for you to add so let's
just say you did 24 7 30 90 and you make
a list of these things underneath I
would say how will it feel when you
accomplish it
how will it feel when you accomplish
what you put your mind to
on a scale of one to ten how does it
feel when you accomplish something you
put your mind to
I see you guys mouthing at 10 right it's
a 10 holding up your hands it's a 10
right
okay but then I want you to do one more
thing after you say how will I feel I'll
feel confident I'll feel courageous I'll
feel fulfilled I'll feel I can do
anything right you write down how you'll
feel
but underneath that I want you to write
down how it'll feel
if you don't mindset number six is rest
and recover with Robin Sharma I think
rest is a secret weapon
there there's a line in the 5am club
which is rest is not a luxury it's a
necessity one of my favorite authors is
Haruki murakami the great Japanese
novelist and he said when I'm not
writing the book I'm writing the book
I mean
you're an author
but it's not any creative any productive
we we beat ourselves up or maybe it's
just me but we beat ourselves up if
we're not doing but how can you
calibrate world-class doing if you don't
make the time for being and so
and so those times where you know nature
or our instinct or our inner artist says
These are times to pull back from the
world and sunbathe and read the classics
and write in a journal and have four
hour meals with the people we love and
travel when it used to be safe to travel
those are not times to feel guilty
John Lennon said time you enjoy wasting
is not wasted time
and so what I've realized is the
greatest productives the greatest
artists the greatest thinkers the
greatest heroes
they were cool with rest and Recovery
they understood that
Elite Performance
is not like a marathon it's more like a
Sprint and the energy project to give
credit where it's due that's they've
evangelized this you know when they talk
about energy it's you know the greatest
productive work in Sprints versus
marathons and so all I'm saying is you
know you're right like life is a series
of seasons and enjoy the seasons and
that's what's going to actually allow
you to play the game for a long time but
also do your greatest work and mindset
number seven the last one before some
very special bonus Clips is live a happy
life with Brian Tracy your Chief in life
should be centered around creating a
happy life for yourself when you are
happy you're able to make those around
you happier it's easy for you to achieve
success overcome challenges and help
others do the same
But first you need to know what makes
you happy and then prioritize your daily
activities and life goals so that you
can achieve lasting happiness most of
the time
it's also important to know that
happiness and success are not
necessarily the same thing for example
you could find success in riches and
wealth but that doesn't necessarily mean
you'll be healthy perhaps you have known
special to share your wealth with or
you're in a career that doesn't bring
you satisfaction
another example is that you could be
successful in your job but that doesn't
necessarily mean that you're happy
it's possible to be good at what you do
and work but not enjoy what you're doing
it may be that something always feels
like it's missing or you want more out
of life
The Familiar saying says money can't buy
happiness also helps to prove the point
that success doesn't always equate to
happiness
although money can help make life easier
and take care of important needs
happiness is a state of mind that is not
dependent on money success or
circumstances
therefore the definition of happiness is
subjective that means it's personal and
emotional and completely up to you to
decide
happiness is a very personal feeling and
you are the only one who can say What
happiness looks like in your own special
life
some feel happy when they know that they
have been honest with themselves and
others and that they are trying to be
the best person they can be
being happy is a state of mind more than
it is something tangible that you have
to strive for and accomplish in one day
living a happy life doesn't mean that
you never experience negative emotions
though setbacks and negative emotions
are a part of life
no matter how happy yours may seem to be
at the moment
however to live a happy life means you
experience positive emotions more often
such as Peace of Mind Joy love
interesting work motivation gratitude
hope and inner satisfaction
so now that you know what happiness is
here are some things that you can do now
to help you find it in your own life
start by looking back on your life and
identify moments when you were truly
happy what were you doing and where were
you doing it what is it that made you
feel happy get a journal and write these
moments down
focus on why you had positive feelings
and what helped to create these feelings
next make a list of the positive
feelings like Serenity motivation
positive self-esteem and others that I
mentioned earlier next to each positive
feeling write down what makes you feel
each emotion what was happening when you
had that experience
it's also important to identify people
in your life and make you feel happy and
support your goals to find happiness
surrounding yourself with positive
people that care about you makes
achieving happiness much easier
you can try new things to see what
brings you happiness you may be
surprised to discover happiness in a new
hobby or a social group or a sport or
activity or a location or a job or other
Pursuits once you know what makes you
happy you must prioritize happiness
while also still striving for success to
propel you forward in life
here are three proven ways to prioritize
both happiness and success first cut out
activities and people that drain you of
happiness it may seem difficult to make
these changes at first but the relief
you'll feel is worse than the effort I
always say when in doubt cut it out
second do more of what makes you happy
from things you've recognized and
learned in the past tell yourself it's
okay to do things that make you happy
you can be a better person for those you
care about when you are truly happy
and lastly number three keep in all open
mind and stay willing to learn new
things
low happiness levels can occur when you
stay stagnant and don't have new
experiences and are constantly moving
lives continue to progress and grow to
stay happy
at the end of the day happiness is the
ultimate level of success we say that
happiness is the achievement of a
worthwhile goal when you're happy you're
successful you've succeeded in life's
main purpose which is to live happily
and well
is saying hey man if you got a million
dollars you're basically just a freaking
deadbeat
and that your daddy didn't tell you that
if you didn't have any more income and
you were how old are you 27 you're 27
years old I'm gonna do this at 47 I'm
gonna do it at uh at at 65. 27 you don't
have any more income how long would that
money last
if four thousand dollars a month
you got 25 years where can you live on
four thousand dollars a month you'd have
to live on four thousand dollars a month
for 25 years you will be 52 years old my
friend and dead broke
number one thing you got to do is this
you got to change the Target and you
need to look at the Target daily the
target you have the wrong Target right
now if you're struggling you have the
wrong target
when you change the target Everything
Changes now and and I started with zero
just so you guys know I didn't have
anything okay so look it's simple Target
what's your new Target
yeah freedom but but but let's put my a
number on it so your first Target should
be 10 million dollars and nothing short
of that number one the target number two
you need to get your income to a place
this is a fascinating concept right here
okay if you can do this I guarantee
you'll be rich
you need to get your income not to what
pays your bills but to where you can
save 40 of your gross income is saved
all right so now now when you do this
math you're like dude how much money do
I actually need let's kick this up to 20
grand at 20 grand what happens
you're saving eight
storage you're paying eight
and now you can live on four see now
this is the right way to do a budget
you make thirty thousand
twelves go into storage
12 is going to the IR and the s
and at least it was six so now you can
start seeing that you got to be
somewhere north of 300 Grand a year this
is what they don't teach you at Harvard
you got to be somewhere north of 360 a
year before you even have money to live
on unless you're just
you know you're a trek
you're just an irresponsible human being
that that's
you know not putting storing money away
for the future
okay now you're saving 12 Grand a month
that's 144 000 in one year in 10 years
that's 1.4 million dollars in 10 years
you're a millionaire stored you guys
need to be heavily Money Motivated from
a survival standpoint okay number three
thing you're gonna do
you're going to go broke right here and
invest
the storage
has to get invested
the Golden Goose is only good If She
lays eggs
otherwise you can kill her eat her for a
chicken
need eggs bait money needs to make
babies
right so your goal right here is to
invest
to invest the storage money
and continue to do that until this money
over here the passive money
is equal
to
your income
[Music]
right so what would I do I'd go out I'm
gonna make 30 grand I'm going to store
12 I'm gonna pay the IRS I'm gonna live
on six Warren Buffett says don't lose
money number one number two don't lose
money
I would tell you number three don't lose
money and that's the reality of the
situation that's what Peter field was
saying a single digit millionaire cannot
even provide themselves with their own
personal defense in America
okay Hulk Hogan all that money Hulk
Hogan made he blew it all
he blew it all probably buying hair
pieces
okay he blew it all he blew it all ended
up with a little money thought he was
this oh man I got a little money until
he had that freaking lawsuit and then he
can't even defend himself
so it happens to a lot of people how
many how many of you know a family
member lost her job
okay how many of you have a family
member where the kid got a drug
addiction he had to go to to rehab for
30 days and it cost 40 Grand that
happens how many of you know somebody
got cancer
okay how many know somebody in your car
accident costs three or four hundred
grand
[Music]
habits
okay the problem is not this happens
happens and people aren't ready for it
oh God I can't believe this happened to
me oh really
God damn you've been around long enough
right how many of you can't swim
[Music]
you live on a planet with water I'm just
saying you might want to get a swimming
lesson
it's a wet Planet when I analyze
businesses
whether they're startups or doing a
hundred million dollars in Revenue
doesn't make a difference
usually there's something in one of
those three or all of those three that
is missing and so when we start to focus
on getting the inner game right plus
what you need to do and then you do it
the results are pretty easy so here's
what I want you to ask yourself
are there people out there
all right that could buy your product or
service but you don't know how to reach
them
right is it possible that there's people
out there that need what you have your
product your service your knowledge your
skills whatever it is that you're
selling offering to the marketplace is
it possible that you just don't know how
to reach them so that means that it's a
skill set issue right now in 2021
we know how to do those things there
like I said earlier where I started
right the fact that there are two
billion people a day online
means that there's more than enough
people to get in front of listen in the
old in the old days right
um when we didn't have the internet we
had to advertise you know the newspapers
postcards magazines radio television or
set up a store in a shopping center
but now just about every single business
okay is online offering information
content to develop a relationship and
rapport with prospects and they're
taking them through a process Yellow
Pages that's right thank you Muse Debbie
Debbie Muse right so yellow pages so
here's the thing one of the formulas
that you must figure out is where I
started before
traffic times conversion equals Revenue
the added version to that is traffic
times conversion plus repeat business
and referrals equals exponential Revenue
traffic times conversion equals Revenue
Now traffic times conversion plus
referrals and repeat business equals
exponential revenue and so one of the
things that you need to be thinking
about okay and if this is the only thing
that you leave today I'm going to give
you a couple things number one is I need
to adapt I need to adapt to the market
and use all the tools available to me
but not use every one of them I want you
to ask yourself the question I posed
earlier is what has to happen in order
for me to just double or triple the
leads that I get
leads the the prospects coming to see
you online or offline if you just
focused on that question
what has to happen in order for me to
double or triple my prospects or leads
and I'm not sure who said that you
picked up the answer Virginia yeah this
is
this is my New York Times best-selling
book The Answer uh if anybody's read it
uh it is a New York Times bestseller for
many many many years now one of the best
books on the inner game and outer game
of business
uh I put that back
over there on my on my thing
um but I didn't come here to to sell you
on my on my book I want to give you
information if anybody wants to get the
book on Amazon uh for 15 or less
um it'll blow your mind and the Lux
Coast you're reading it now awesome so
when we understand there's already a
process in place
and we discover how do we take our
product or service and create the
marketing how many of you are you good
in marketing
are you good in marketing meaning I'm
not talking about branding I'm talking
about getting your product or service
with the right message in front of the
ideal client
if you're not good at marketing okay I
want you to let me know are you good at
marketing yes or no so you're not good
at marketing
think about this if you're a business
owner there's a couple of different hats
that you have to make sure are being
taken care of right in business if
you're a business owner with a product
or service you have to have somebody
who's doing the marketing right which is
developing your brand creating your
messaging for how you're going to
promote your product or service to
people who don't know you you have to
learn how to sell and selling is doing
something for somebody not to somebody
uh you need to learn how to manage you
need to learn how to either develop
products you need to learn some of the
technology needs that you have there's a
lot of different hats that you have to
wear
or you have to make sure that somebody
in your company is wearing that hat
right and so imagine if you're um needs
surgery but you're not a good surgeon
what would you do you'd have to find how
do I get somebody who could do the
surgery so for those of you who are not
good at marketing or sales which is the
oxygen required for any business
regardless of how good your product or
service are the question you want to be
asking yourself is this who can I hire
to help me or who can I barter with to
help me who can I partner with to help
me do my marketing and sales if you're
not good at that so higher partner
barter or defer payment to get it done
because without
marketing and selling
you really don't have a business and
those are skills that either you have
that you need to develop or you don't
have you're not good at you don't want
it but you still need to figure out as a
business owner how am I going to get it
done your job as a business owner is not
to do everything but to make sure that
everything that is oxygen and is
required gets done self-confidence comes
from doing difficult things
self-confidence self-love self-respect
it all comes from deciding to do
something difficult
here's what happens when when something
hard comes up and you find a reason why
you can't do it it's too hard it's too
difficult it's too scary
most people will let you off the hook
the people around you will say yeah yeah
that's way too hard I mean the fact you
even thought about it was crazy
let yourself off the hook
but then you realize
done it you know like that's the worst
feeling in the world that you could have
done something
but then you came up with an excuse as
to why you can't
and that will eat you up
and even if the world lets you off the
hook
recognize that they have lower standards
than you
recognize that the people who are giving
you that advice and padding on the back
and saying it's okay you don't need to
do it
they don't like their life either
they're stuck they're trapped
they're not pushing hard they're not
being aggressive for their goals they're
not tough either
and we're reinforcing that Comfort Loop
every day comfort you versus growth you
are in a fight there's a war going on
inside you comfort you versus growth you
comfort Evan birth is growth Evan every
day there's a fight there's a battle
there's a war going on and you need to
decide who's gonna win the fight
it's a daily thing and the more growth
you wins against comfort you the more
you start to grow the more you start to
hit your goals the more you start to
have an impact the more you start to
love yourself
[Music]
because again even if the world would
let you off the hook
you know it's just an excuse
I think most people think of it as a
giant step that you have to take to
build that self-confidence it's not I
think it's much more about the daily
battles with yourself that then builds
up to Major things just like you don't
go to the gym and lift 400 pounds you
start by lifting five pounds or ten
pounds or 20 pounds or 40 pounds
whatever it is that's how you start to
build the muscle it's much more about
the Daily building of the muscle to show
yourself who you are much more than the
one-off heroic moments here's an example
so uh yesterday we had an insane
snowstorm here in Toronto I don't know
if we can it's kind of blurry can't see
we had like you see some here behind me
it's like look at see that mountain of
snow behind me we had an insane
snowstorm we had probably the worst
snowstorm in Toronto Canada in the
decade I have not seen this much snow in
a crazy amount of time and so I'm going
for a walk
uh rocking and rucking is where you
carry a backpack so I'm carrying a
backpack of 20 pounds
as I'm walking doing my normal walk and
it's it's crazy outside normally the
rucking alone is hard enough and I just
increased the weight in the backpack now
I there's no path to wacon and this
morning I was walking through an area
and there was Zero path the snow is up
to my knees and I need to get through
so what's what are my options well I
could I could complain and turn around
right like I could look out the window
and say ah so much snow I'm not gonna do
that I'll do it when there's less snow
you know and then the next day there's
less snow there's still snow in the next
it's still snow and then all of a sudden
you just gave up on the Habit right like
you let yourself off the hook to say
I'll do it tomorrow and then and then
you never do it and then the habit's
gone and that's what you're teaching
yourself this is why it leads to
Identity this is why it leads to
negative self-worth and negative
self-confidence because the next time
you come up with an idea you've already
reinforced the training you're training
yourself that when you come up with an
idea you don't do the thing when you say
you're gonna do it and you're gonna
start tomorrow and then you don't the
next time you come up with an idea guess
what you you've already reinforced the
pattern I don't follow through I'm not
gonna do that I'm excited today but
tomorrow I won't follow through
so there's a snow is up to my knees
right up to my knees and I'm six one so
it's it's some serious snow like I gotta
walk through not quite that that's
that's probably taller than me uh I
don't have to walk through that much but
but up to my knees
I'm looking at it and I've got to go I
don't know
100 meters
through this thing
and initially my thought was oh man why
is there no path why is nobody shoveled
this why has nobody still Blowfish like
gotta get over there I got a backpack on
I'm rocking I'm sweating like crazy I'm
already exhausted now I gotta go through
this
this is when we need to catch ourselves
right everybody would have let me off
the hook
and another me would have let me off the
hook right Comfort Evan would have let
growth happen off the hook so that's
okay go back home
or go the long way around where there's
a path don't go through that snoped your
knees
and as soon as I caught it
now what
most of the time you won't catch it most
of the time you'll just do
you'll do the automatic thing and
usually the automatic thing is is the
comfort thing so usually play small by
default usually you you'll look outside
and see the snow and not go just by
default not even catching the the
conversation with yourself
but when you catch it
this is a really important moment what
do you do do you do the difficult thing
or do the comfort thing
because when you catch it and you make a
conscious choice this is how we start to
either change our Identity or reinforce
our identity
so I looked at it I caught it and said
I'm going through let's go you know I
caught the negative thinking I caught
the Comfort Evan coming over walk around
go home nope not happening we're going
through we are going through we're gonna
make it through
and it was rough
you know I'm walking through I'm
freezing uh I'm taking one kind of giant
step at a time snow is getting all
through my boots all down my legs I I
almost slip and fall I have a coffee
that I that I picked up uh it's dripping
all over the place
and in my head as I'm going through it
it's like this is the best
let's go let's go Evan you got this man
let's go
you do difficult things that's the thing
on repeat in my head
combined with that
I'm also telling myself that you know
what not only am I doing this difficult
thing for me I'm also creating a path
for other people that the next person
who comes up against this 100 meters or
so that now they will have not an easy
time but an easier time of crossing the
same path
so they can get across
so it's going to service
if you're ever having a hard time
getting yourself to do something
it's one you do difficult things remind
yourself and two default the service
that it's not just about you it's for
other people now that may not even be
true
maybe nobody ever comes across that path
maybe I didn't make it easier for the
next person maybe somebody comes five
minutes after me and snow blows the
whole thing and so there was Zero
service
it doesn't matter it's the story that
I'm telling myself that it will serve
other people that will get you to then
do the difficult thing
so in order to make it happen
there's two triggers that I use one is
language so scary difficult or hard if
you say those things if you feel those
things if you text those things if you
write those things if you're talking to
yourself and you catch those things then
you have to do it you can no longer
accept scary difficult or hard as
reasons for you not to do the thing
because your great life is on the other
side of scary difficult heart everything
you want the business you want the
relationships you want the help that you
want everything everything your great
life if you wrote down a list of
everything you want out of life
everything on that list comes on the
other side of you doing scary difficult
and hard things
growth you that's growth you fighting
comfort you
so when you catch yourself sane speaking
writing thinking scary difficult to
heart that's a that's a trigger it
should be a trigger it's a trigger for
me it should be a trigger for you to go
and do it do it go walk through the
giant snow and you might be thinking
well how does that help me with my
business it's just walking through snow
and I'm going to be cold and have snow
in my boots how does that help me
it's an identity thing
because as soon as you start to teach
yourself that you're the kind of person
who follows through on those scary
difficult hard things
then the next time that shows up
anywhere in your life in your business
and your relationships and your health
anything that actually helps you
accomplish your goals you're going to be
ready to show up for it you're going to
be more likely to actually do the thing
because you've been training and
conditioning yourself to do the thing
that's why walking through 100 meters of
snow matters
so the first is scary difficult hard
those are verbal cues or thought cues
the second is the boom boom boom test
where your heart is beating quickly it's
like when your heart is going crazy like
that
it's usually because you should be doing
something you're afraid right now don't
again go don't go don't go standing on
the highway uh because it's scary and it
makes your heart race right don't be
stupid but most of the things that
you're afraid of
aren't actually things that are going to
be life-threatening
right they're not they're usually it's
other people's opinions usually you're
afraid of not failing but somebody
watching you fail right you're gonna
fail at something who's gonna see you
that's what we're actually afraid of and
that cannot be a good enough reason it
can't not anymore if you're afraid of
losing in front of somebody if you're
afraid of other people's opinions if you
are living your life based off of the
expectations and Judgment of other
people you will never do anything great
you will never live your great life
because somebody always has a plan for
what you should be doing with your life
you will never please everybody it's not
possible
you have to start to learn to please
yourself and it's not doing something
just to show off and just to prove
somebody wrong I'm not a big fan of
tapping into that energy the reason to
do something is not to prove somebody
wrong and make somebody else look stupid
the reason to do something is because
that's who you are and that's what you
want to do
and so learning to do difficult things
teaching yourself step by step RIP by
Brick one snow storm at a time
teaching yourself that
will change your life
you deserve a better life
you deserve a great life
when that comes on the other side of you
doing the things that are scary
difficult and hard
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for the
most eye-opening 60 Minutes of your life
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there here's the hard
truth about getting great it takes time
and dedication it takes a willingness to
accept that you're not yet good enough
it takes the ability to stare at the
places that you know that you're weak